bonsoir dans 5 des SEP communes de
l'agglomération cinquantinoise il aura
suffi d'un seul tour dimanche dernier
pour connaître la liste gagnante c'est
le cas à Montini le Bretonneux Guill en
courour et hlen courour voilà Montin
avec Michel logier Guill en courour avec
François deignier hlen courour avec
Jean-Michel Fourgous sous les maires
sortant ont donc été réélus dès le
premier tour à Mani Lamo et et à la
verrière Bertron Ouillon et Alain agjage
candidat au suffrage universel pour la
première fois ont également été élus au
premier tour il reste il reste donc deux
communes à pourvoir celle de trappe où
une triangulaire sera proposée aux
électeurs entre le maire sortant guim
Malandin otman naserou pour l'UMP et Luc
Mr pour le Front de gauche et puis à
voisin le Bretonneux et c'est ce qui va
nous intéresser ce soir il y aura aussi
une triangulaire entre vous trois trois
candidats qui sont au plateau avec moi
ce soir bonsoir bonsoir d'abord Alexis
Biet vous êtes le maire sortant vous
briguez un 4e mand mandat Alexandra
Rosetti bonsoir vous étiez l'ancienne
maire adjointe d'Alexis Biet vous avez
quitté ce poste en octobre 2013 pour
lancer votre propre liste et vous êtes
également au 2ème tour et puis Jean hche
ê bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
municipale d'opposition d'ERS gauche et
puis je rappelle que vos temps de
paroles seront chronométrés pour
l'équilibre du débat on va commencer par
regarder vos résultats à l'issue de ce
premier tour donc dimanche dernier
Alexis bi vous êtes arrivé en tête avec
un peu plus de 39 % des voix Alexandra
Rosetti en 2e position à 28 % Jean 3e
position à 19 % et puis Jean-Louis
qu'son 12 % je voudrais d'abord une une
réaction sur ces premiers résultats de
de 2014 Alexis Biet 6 points de plus
qu'en 2008 ça vous satisfait bah oui ça
montre que nous le bilan a été apprécié
et que le projet et l'équipe que j'ai
présenté ont eu un écho puisque nous
sommes en net en nette progression donc
pas de dispersion des voies de la droite
c'est ce que vous avez vous avez eu
tendance à craindre avant ce premier
tour B il y a eu une dispersion puisque
il y a trois listes qui se revendiquent
de la droite hein moi je j'appelle à un
rassemblement hein je crois qu'au
premier tour effectivement on peut se
permettre quelquefois de
présenter autre chose hein mais après je
pense que il faut se réunir par par
rapport au aux enjeux effectivement qui
sont importants au niveau communal et au
niveau intercommunal Jean h vous vous
avez fait 9 points de moins qu'en
2008 alors en fait moi moi le premier
point qui que je relève c'est le taux
d'abstention il a quand même été énorme
TR points de moins TR points de
moins 57 % seulement de votant je crois
que c'est le premier renseignement du
vote il faut vraiment mobiliser les
électeurs le fait que mes points soient
un peu moins importants qu'en 2008 ne ne
se passe pas de la même façon puisque
les les conditions du vote nétaient pas
les mêmes voilà alors pourquoi les
conditions du vote étaient pas les mê
parpulation change d'acc parce qu'en
2008 il y avait aussi la même
configuration trois listes de droite une
liste de gauche honnêtement je peux dire
que je m'attendais à avir entre 20 20 et
25 plutôt autour de 25 il y a 20 bon 19
entre 19 et 20 mais quand vous dites les
conditions de vote non c'està dire je je
je je pense je pense que l'électorat n'a
pas été suffisamment mobilisé pour le
premier tour électorat gauche notamment
l'lectorat gauche et ça donne plein
d'espoir pour le deuxème tour d'accord
vous vous en doutez oui Alexandra
Rosetti alors vous n'étiez pas vous tête
de liste en 2008 vous avez fait 28 %
c'est un score que vous jugez
encourageant ah bah oui parce que quand
on pense que je suis parti de rien et
que j'ai le soutien d'absolument aucun
parti je trouve que ça veut bien dire
que les les vcinois ont peut-être envie
de changer de changer de mer je remarque
quand même que même si tu trouves que
c'est très satisfaisant comme résultat
c'est quand même au premier tour pour un
M sortant C chinois sur 10 qui
n'accordent pas qui ne renouvelle pas
leur confiance donc je pense qu'il faut
entendre ça euh donc moi je suis
vraiment très contente de ce résultat je
pense que effectivement les gens doivent
encore se mobiliser retourner voter
dimanche y aller s'ils étaient pas aller
avant afin de de faire entendre leur
leur choix vous voulez répondre à oui
j'ai déjà entendu ce même argument en
2008 avec Joë Lenan et et André de Sousa
je ça ça ça veut rien dire je pense que
est-ce que si moi je dis ah bah oui donc
il y a 72 % des visinois qui ne vous
veulent pas
pasortant ça ne veut rien dire ça ne
veut rien dire il y a un il y il y a un
projet une équipe voilà qui est a été
mis en tête hein qui a été
préféré préféré par les Vinois
heureusement ben donc on
a v de droite excuse-moi mais
vous avez dit que j'avais un bon bilan
bon donc vous donc vous le partagez pas
tout hein
donc il y a bien une différence il y a
pas de souci je vais m'expliquer oui moi
je je pense que ce débat est un peu
stérile ne sert à rien le le les les
égos des uns et des autres à droite ne
m'intéressent pas il n'intéressent pas
les viilles Chinois je crois qu'il faut
aller au fond du problème pour le
deuxème tour alors on va parler de vos
priorités pour la campagne mais je
voudrais quand même aussi encore un
petit mot sur Jean-Louis quison puisquil
a fait 12 % des voix il aura a pu se
maintenir et faire une pridre angulaire
et puis du coup il a décidé de ne pas se
maintenir d'arrêter l'aventure au profit
de vous Alexandre arosity puisqu'il app
à voter pour vous Alexis Biet vous vous
regrettez ce choix de Jean-Lou titison
parce que dimanche vous aviez laissé
sous entendre que vous aimeriez bien que
les électeurs jtison votent plutôt pour
vous ah non j'étais pas au courant de sa
de sa position qui vient de faire
connaître là tout à l'heure dans un
communiqué de de presse et je pense que
on n'est pas propriétaire je pense des
voix de ces électeurs parce que là par
exemple au début au début de de
l'émission vous avez parlé de rassembler
de rassembler l'ensemble des électeurs
est-ce que c'est aussi un appel que vous
lancez aux électeurs de jeanouizon non
mais ce que je vois c'est que il n'y a
pas de volonté de de rassemblement mais
plutôt d'être contre un homme malgré son
bilan et son équipe c'est ce que je
remarque de la part de Jean-Louis tison
et d'Alexandre arosetti Aland alors
absolument pas mais alors vraiment ça je
pense que je pense que de des trois
listes c'est moi qui est le discours le
plus rassembleur je suis désolé je suis
pas moi je tape pas ah non je ne tape
pas sur les électeurs de de gauche je
respecte les habitants dans leur dans
leurs opinions ce que ce qui n'est pas
fait jusqu'à présent je veux dire tu as
toutes les étiquettes je te l'ai déjà
dit c'est c'est formidable n'empêche que
ça veut dire qu'il y a une partie des
électeurs qu'on méprise et ben moi je
trouve ça très dommage et mon
positionnement centriste et je suis
centriste depuis 10 ans mon
positionnement centriste me permet
justement
d'appeler à se fédérer et se rassembler
autour d'un projet qui je dirais comme
comme le tiens comme de Monsieur H pour
le bien de la commune je crois qu'on a
tous la même alors les égos excuse-moi
je maiscuse-moi ça oui souvent plus
c'est les hommes
que vous allez pas jouer vous
allezar je veux pas jouer l'arbitre
entre les égos des listes de droite ce
n'est pas mon problème on est là pour
parler du projet que l'on veut à la fois
pour voisin pour la comité
d'agglomération et c'est de ça dont je
voudrais que nous parlions et on pourra
parler du bilan que je qualifierai de
désastreux d'Alexis Biet et du
changement que propose Alexandra Rosetti
qui pour moi n'existe pas d'accord les
choses sont claires alors vous avez la
parole juste sur sur sur les étiquettes
je sais pas pourquoi est-ce que Madame
Rosetti à ce
moment-là j'ai ma carte à j'ai ma carte
à
l' et donc donc c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt par dépit de dire ça parce que
euh votre parti votre parti ne vous
reconnaît pas et ne vous soutient pas
bien sûr parce que mon je m'exliquer la
je ve m'exliquer la ça va faire un déb
al parce que vous avez parlé
d'intercommunalité je voudrais justement
qu'on en parle de cette intercommunalité
parce que là l'enjeu effectivement il
est évidemment pour l'élection la
réélection du du maire à voisin de
Bretonneux mais il est aussi sur
l'agglomération centinoise elle pourrait
basculer à droite à l'issue de ce
premier tour la droite a quand même viré
en tête en nombre de conseillers
communautaires il y a 20 conseillers
pour la droite et 14 conseillers pour la
gauche il reste 14 conseillers
communautaires à élir trappe qui en
compte 10 et voisins de brantonux qui en
compte qui en compte qu voilà tout à
fait avant de vous faire réagir et
savoir un petit peu ce que vous en
pensez je voudrais qu'on écoute Stéphane
Manson alors en toute transparence je le
dis il est candidat sur la liste de Jean
h mais nous on l'a sur on l'interview
surtout on l' missionné voilà alors nous
on l'intervie surtout Stéphan parce que
c'est un expert c'est un peu notre
expert à TVFI il est professeur de droit
public à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin et pour lui les jeux
semblent tout foi fait on
l'écoute tout dépend de la façon dont
les victoires seront remportées si si si
on peut parier sur des victoires très
larges ou sur des défaites très larges
elles aussi mais il y a de très fortes
probabilités au regarde des observations
qu'on peut faire des projections que
l'on peut faire pour qu'en effet la
communauté d'agglomération bascule
bascule à droite les clés oui c'est
c'est évidemment sur alors surtout trap
puisque trap dispose d'un nombre de
sièges assez assez considérable fait
partie des grandes communes de
l'agglomération et c'est donc bah
pratiquement attrape que que ça va se
décider à voisin le Bretonneux la
question est paraît désormais réglée et
c'est donc attrape que tout va se jouer
voilà rrape tout va se jouer d'après
Stéphane Manson la question réglée à
voisin le le BR voilà on va regarder vos
temps de parole avant de vous donner les
la réponse jeage vous avez beaucoup de
retard vous avez mis de retard sur
Alexis Biet euh alors en terme de
projection à l'issu de ce ce premier de
ce deuxème tour si on se projette la
gauche pourrait obtenir entre 22 et 24
sièges à l'agglomération la droite entre
24 et 26 sièges et puis en cas d'égalité
entre les deux tours euh et bien la
prime sera donnée au candidat à la
présidence qui est le plus âgé et en
l'occurrence sur les candidats les plus
âgés actuellement ce serait guimalandin
euh donc s'il est rélu à trappe
évidemment
alors qu'en pensez-vous alors moi moi
d'abord je voudrais je voudrais faire
remarquer que les élections ce ne sont
pas des mathématiques oui et que il faut
pas accumuler les voix du premier tour
il passera comme ça au de il y il y a
une réalité c'est une réalité aussi mais
je rappelle qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'abstention et que beaucoup de
d'électeurs n'étaient pas conscients de
l'enjeu du vote pour l'agglomération et
c'est grâce au résultat du premier tour
que les électeurs prennent conscience de
l'Ance de cet enjeu et pour nous il est
clair que la communé d'agglomération
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin est une
réussite c'est une réussite du point de
vue développement économique c'est une
réussite du point de vue vie culturel
c'est point une réussite du point de vue
des activités du cadre de vie et il faut
absolument que cette réussite continue
et se perpétue et pour ça il faut
absolument que l'agglomération reste à
gauche et c'est le l'effort l'axe
porteur que l'on veut faire pour notre
deuxème tour faire en sorte que voisins
se réveill plutôt que reste endormi et
dis je veux être un acteur important
pour l'agglomération je veux donc qu'il
y ait un délégué de gauche à
l'agglomération pour ça l'enjeu est
clair il faut qu'on soit second oui il
faut que vous soz second et c'est bien
notre objectif puisque on est réaliste
on sera pas premier mais nous voulons
être second Alex que pensez-vous alors
de cette situation au niveau de
l'agglomération est-ce que effectivement
là vous êtes quand il a voisin Brot
c'est très important que les électeurs
sachent ça parce que les électeurs
n'avaient pas compris la façon dont les
délégués étent
et même monsieur B di soir me dit vous
aurez un délégué alors qu'il savait que
c'était 3e lui-même avait peut-être pas
compris le mode d'élection ça dépend du
pourcentage je crois que St a tout à
fait effectivement ça dépend pas du
pourcentage qu' a une prime qui est
donnée au gagnant et ce sera le deuxème
arrivé au deuxème tour qui aura le
conseiller communautaire supplémentaire
parce qu'à voisin on en a que qure si on
en avvez eu 5 ça a été différent vous
avez refusé on a pas refusé on a
appliqué la loi qui qui est une loi
vousz refusé les 10 %lémentaires qui
étaient possible plus juste qui donne
une
proportionnalité et d'ailleurs on voit
le résultat hein puisque maintenant il y
a presque une égalité qui va qui va se
jouer et il faut attendre les résultats
c'est vrai de de trappe et de et de
voisin hein pour savoir exactement ce
qui se passera si il y a une majorité à
droite et bien il y aura je pense une
nouvelle gouvernance et nouveau nouvel
élan à cette communauté d'agglomération
et une agglomération je dirais au au au
service de l'ensemble des des communes
de toutes les communes on va dire et
aussi une cohérence du territoire auquel
il faut il faut aller euh pour coller à
notre bassin de vie regard et puis après
on va
parlerê dire quelque chose là-dessus
parcece que je vois que de nouveau de
nouveau nous sommes toujours dans les
étiquettes hein le les partis et cetera
je pense que j'espère j'ose espérer que
quel que soit euh je dirais le bord qui
va l'emporter bah ils auront toujours à
cœur de faire cette agglomération reste
dynamique vivante et et comme nous
l'aimons tous donc moi je suis là pour
parler de la commune aussi parce que je
veux dire dire on va voter à gauche pour
pas que pour pas que la communauté
d'Aglou passe à droite enfin où est-ce
qu'on parle de la commune je pense que
je pense qu' est essentiel mais vraiment
essentiel c'est de savoir travailler
avec toutes les personnes tous nos
partenaires quel que soit leur bord moi
j'ai une position centriste justement
donc je veux dire moi je me sens en
capacité de travailler avec des ulus
qu'il soit de gauche ou de droite tout
ce qu'on veut c'est le bien et de nos
communes et de la communauté
d'agglomération donc je trouve que ces
querelles gauche- droite je pense que
j'imagine que les je suis pas d'accord
c'est pas une querelle gauche- droite
c'est que voisin est une commune de la
communauté d'agglomération et l'avenir
de voisin dépend du devenir de la
communité d'agglomération et on est
confronté à deux points de vuees
différents qui sont pas des questions
sont de partis politique un point de vue
passéiste qui est bâti sur le bassin de
vie et
un une vision beaucoup plus long terme
qui veut profiter de tout le
développement scientifique et technique
que l'opération de Paris Sacé va
conduire et je pense que pour voisin
c'est très important que l'extension de
l'agglomération se fasse vers Paris sa
clé plutôt que vers le bassin de vie
plaisir les clés et cetera et donc c'est
très important puisque voisin n'est pas
isolé voisin doit être un acteur
volontariste de l'agglomération et il
faut absolument aussi que voisin profite
de la mutualisation que permet
l'agglomération de devenir
l'agglomération et vers quelle
agglomération autre agglomérationion on
a
l'occasion je vraisigner du coup voyez
entre entre ces bagarres gauche droite
l'importance d' regard son tristes
justement c'est pas des
bagares des BAGAR passé avenir différent
des vision de l'avenir du
territoire c'est très important de viser
sa clé Monsieur H euh d'enjambber euh le
golf la ceinture de lineras euh et et et
man Lamo je ne crois pas vraiment que ce
soit une une une bonne méthode et notre
risque c'est de devenir la banlieue de
saclé il vaut mieux que assurer une
cohérence de notre bassin de vie o
actuellement on a des centres
commerciaux qui se
créent dans toute la périphérie de
saintanttin je pense qu'il y a un
travail en commun à faire et une
répartition sera messieur je vous a sur
l'agglomération c'est vrai qu' on sait
pas encore quelle couleur aura
l'agglomération on aura l'occasion de
reparler évidemment de de l'évolution de
cette agglomération soit vers Leyen du
plateau de Sacla soit un retour vers
mourpa coignère plaisir plaisir les
Clais on va parler quand même on va
revenir sur la campagne à voisin
brotonux il reste très peu de jours
l'entre deux tours on sait c'est
toujours une période un peu un peu dur
un peu fatigante quel quel est le
message principal que vous voulez
délivrer à vos électeurs chacun à l'
tibiillettes ah bah le le message c'est
la mobilisation hein bien sûr et c'est
de répondre je dirais au aux questions
qui se sont posées pendant cette
campagne c'est l'avantage d'avoir un
deuxième tour c'est que on on on a fait
une campagne et donc là on peut répondre
aux électeurs et nous nous organisons
une réunion jeudi
prochain en mairie avec comme avec la
participation d'Iv van valall qui est
notre conseiller général ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas politique c'est pas
politique c'est notre conseiller général
qui a les compétences VI départemental
sur nos routes et sur tu peux pas parler
seul donc tu as besoin forcément de
quelqu'un pour vir parler avec toi je
t'ai pas interrompu je vous ai pas
interrompu hein merci de me respecter
c'est en même temps respecter les
électeurs oui d'accord on vaarler et
donc il y a des questions qui se posent
notamment en terme de circulation de
transport d'environnement de protection
du du parc avec des solutions qui ont
été avancées dans cette campagne et donc
là ça va être l'occasion et bien de
pouvoir justement en parler et y
répondre alors alexandreosit allez vous
avez la parole oui oui c'est vrai je
trépigne un petit peu je suis désolé
qu-ce que vous avez envie de dire à vos
é moi env dire de de reprendre mon
programme et de le bien le relire parce
que là j'ai un très joli tract que j'ai
eu cette semaine j'avoue que c'est un un
comment dirais-je une prouesse de
manipulation de ce que j'ai pu dire donc
vraiment j'ai dans mon programme j'ai
voulu lui donner du sens j'ai voulu
montrer que j'avais réfléchi que nous
avions réfléchi à ce que nous voulions
faire donc quand je lis que je veux
faire une nouvelle voie au cœur du parc
naturel régional avec ça passe dans
l'école de la derrière l'école de la S
de la carrière que ça traverse le
domaine de la croix du bois donc je vais
faire une autoroute à voisin je n'ai
jamais je n'ai jamais écrit ça VO de
contournement une voie de contournement
est-ce que j'ai dit par où elle passait
est-ce que je l'ai dit non ce non j'ai
pas dit exactement par où elle passa par
le sud tu vois c'est c'est toi qui me
laisse pas parler là donc je veux partir
je pense que cette voix elle doit partir
au niveau du CV7 et elle doit terminer
non je ne l'ai pas je ne l'ai pas dit si
non bon ben ce sera sûrement sur ton
site puisque tu me filmes à mon insu
donc de toute façon ça y sera quelle
ambiance laagne oui non mais c'est bon
je veux dire quand on beaucoup plus
clean non non je veux c'est pas une
question d'être clean c'est une question
de pas faire manipuler ce qu'on dit donc
je ne fais pas de voix de contournement
au ras je
finisliationliation je ne fais pas de
voie de contournement au rat des maisons
cette voie de contournement elle doit
être étudiée avec Mani elle peut partir
j'ai quelqu'un dans ma liste qui
travaille justement circulation
transport c'est son c'est son domaine
c'est sa spécialité elle doit partir du
côté du CV7 d'accord c'estàdire au
rondpoint de Man et trouver une solution
pour arriver du côté du golf à quel
moment ça traverse la croix du bois mais
bon je vois que tu parles à ma place je
suis trs
cont j'ai 15es mais c'est
lui dis simplement que là c'est un tissu
de mensonge et c'est un tissu
d'approximation donc moi j'appelle les
gens avant de croire tout ce qui est
écrit à prendre les programmes à se
replonger dedans et à voir comment ils
ont été écrits voilà c'est tout ce que
je leur demande il mérite des précisions
effectivement je pense oui je pense jeou
alors moi moi d'abord je voudrais quand
même dire je l'ai dit en entrée que je
considère que le bilan de Monsieur Biet
est désastreux des d'impcurordre rien
sur les transports la circulation si ce
n'est des petites opérations rustines
l'aménagement de la remise complètement
bloqué et cetera je vais pas aller dans
le détail je considère aussi que
Alexandra rositi n'apporte aucun
changement n'oublions pas qu'elle est
mêlée à tout ce qui s'est passé ces 13
dernières années quoi qu'ell disent et
qu'il n pas de changement à venir je
crois aussi que le programme justement
est un programme ramasse tout et qui a
pas de cohérence et pas de vision bien
nous nous avons un programme très
cohérent très clair je sais très bien
que nous ne serons pas majoritaires mais
je voudrais dire que en plus mon
expérience n'oublions pas que je suis
élu depuis 95 mon expérience c'est qu'il
faut une opposition constructive et
quand je regarde l'opposition qui a eu
lieu pendant les 19 années pendant
lesquell j'étais conseiller municipal ce
n'est que la gauche qui a apporté une
opposition constructive la droite étant
une opposition au règlement de compte et
donc moi j'invite les Vinois à voter en
masse pour nous pour qu'au moins il y
ait une opposition qui travaille pour
les Vinois d'accord euh ce débat est
presque terminé je voudrais juste
refaire un tour de table et de vous
donner un mot de conclusion à chacun
vous avez 30 secondes chacun pour
écoutez à la fin de cette campagne j'ai
pu présenter un projet une équipe tout
d'abord que voisin continue à être la
ville des familles avec une adaptation
des services aux besoins de ces de ces
habitants que voisin conserve un cadre
de vie de qualité avec plus de
concertation encore sur les différents
aménagements les proportions seront
maîtriser la mixité sociale exemplaire
et la gestion de voisin sera la
meilleure toujours de 50 anine c'est les
échos qui viennent d'ailleurs d'analyser
oui qui viennent d'analyser la gestion
financière des communes de France nous
sommes la meilleure de SaintQuentin en
yville et bien donc on continue g r vous
couper alexandreosti pour le parole et
ben moi c'est pareil j'invite j'invite
les Vinois à se positionner vraiment
pour un autre regard un vrai autre
regard avec une équipe que mè sortant
qualifie d'héteroclit mais qui en fait
est très très diverse et c'est ça qui
fait toute sa richesse c'est une équipe
extrêmement motivée et puis je pense que
effectivement si je dis que le bilan
n'est pas mauvais c'est parce que on est
bien un voisin on est tous d'accord mais
moi je pense que maintenant il est
nécessaire d'avoir une vraie maîtrise
des dépenses une vraie maîtrise de
l'urbanisation et de la circulation et
puis le mot concertation il est bien
joli mais je crois que il faut
travailler avec les habitants la
concertation elle doit être avant tout
absolument sincère voilà très bien vous
avez tenu votre temps de parole c'est
parf ou moi je
vousraiss moi moi moi je voudrais
inviter tous les Vinois à voter vraiment
sans exc sans excl il faut que tout le
monde aille voter c'est le premier point
le deuxème point je voudrais rappeler
qu'on est une équipe cohérente unie qui
est basée sur des valeurs qui propose un
développement harmonieux qui propose des
règles d'économie d'énergie qui propose
des actions au niveau des transports
collectifs qui qui propose une vraie
concertation dès la monond du projet
j'ai toujours considéré que
effectivement alexibiette et y compris
Alexandra puisquelle était responsable
de la démocratie locale ne savait pas
faire de la concertation et je veux un
partenariat constructif avec le comité
deacamoration et je rappelle le premier
le second point qui est très important
c'est que le vote de dimanche prochain
est un second tour qui est crucial pour
5 Quentin et j'invite vraiment les
électeurs vcinois à dire nous voulons
que Saint-Quentin continue dans sa
dynamique actuelle voilà ben merci en
tout cas à vous trois d'être venu sur le
plateau on va afficher vos temps de
parole respectif je crois que vous êtes
pratiquement tous à égalité voilà à peu
près à discon bah c'est parfait vous
avez vraiment respecté les je vous
félicite donc merci à vous de FO d'être
venu sur le plateau de municipal 2014 je
vous rappelle évidemment que le deuxème
tour des municipales ce sera dimanche 30
mars et évidemment je vous invite à
aller voter à cette occasion l'ensemble
de la rédaction de téléfil se mobilise
comme la semaine dernière pour vous
faire vivre ce deuxè tour en direct à
partir de 19h45 jusqu'à peut-être 23h30
minuit en fonction des résultats qui
tomberont dans les communes qui nous
intéressent plus précisément voisin le
Bretonneux trappe morpa ou encore sains
à l'école on ira également du côté de
Rambouillet je vous souhaite une
excellente
soirée y